la guerre de l'image a encore frappé en
Ukraine les 27 ministres des Affaires
étrangères se retrouvent donc à Kiev ce
lundi c'est du jamais vu depuis
l'invasion russe c'est une manière de
répondre aux espoirs de Moscou non le
camp occidental n'est pas fatigué il
poursuit son aide à l'Ukraine bonjour
Emmanuel Chaze on vous retrouve sur
place à Kiev l'idée bien sûr c'est de
rassurer les autorités ukrainiennes
bonjour Julien oui tout à fait c'est une
visite qui est avant tout au symbolique
c'est la première fois que tous les 27
ministres des Affaires étrangères de
l'Union européenne se réunissent en
dehors du bloc de l'Union et quel
symbole qui qui accueille avec
soulagement je dirais ces ministres pour
discuter de plusieurs sujets majeurs non
seulement l'aide militaire européenne
accordée à l'Ukraine mais aussi les
sanctions contre la la Russie ou encore
bien évidemment l'accession de l'Ukraine
à l'Union européenne avec ses
déclarations de la ministre des Affaires
étrangères allemandes d'Anna Léna
berbock qui a dit il y a quelques
instants que bientôt l'Union européenne
s'est tendrait de Lisbonne à Luans je le
rappelle qui est une ville
occupée dans l'est de l'Ukraine occupé
par la Russie depuis 2014 donc à une
grande démonstration d'unité une grande
démonstration de sol avec Joseph Borel
le plus représentant de l'Union
européenne ici à Kiev qui a également
déclaré que ce soutien et bien il
n'était pas conditionnel aux avancées ou
non de l'armée ukrainienne sur le
terrain et qui se prolongerait aussi
longtemps que possible merci beaucoup
Emmanuel chaise pour ces éléments voilà